[Applause]
thank you I think I know why you're
happy because the big March for Life
rally happened today did you
and why was anybody at the March for
life you know while back in Washington
prep President Trump the first president
sitting president ever to address a
march for life rally and he did not
disappoint these people boy it was all
about how great it is to bring as many
babies into the world that you can it
was like a trump rally at one point the
crowd was chanting knock her up
was Evangelic oh they love Trump even
though he knows [ __ ] about Christianity
and makes everything about himself he
was trying to talk to they said told us
rally said Jesus was persecuted from the
day he came down the escalator Trump was
very clear no abortion all the only
exceptions are rape incest and the looks
of the mother and hey you and to those
skeptics who think Trump is not sincere
about this he put that to rest
he said if I thought abortion was not an
option how do you explain Eric
but so the media has a new thing to whip
up a public panic about the corona virus
are you into the corona virus okay
started in China and quickly moved and
spread to Japan and South Korea and
Thailand and Taiwan and the United
States now and health officials are
worried they say this is how kpop got
started
but it was likely they'd say started in
I'm so glad Ingrid Newkirk is here
tonight she can talk about this in an
exotic Chinese food market where they
sell things where people eat things like
salamanders and bats and snakes don't
even ask about the dollar menu because
it's just pigs [ __ ] it's terrible I
once ate in one of these flow it was
years ago I was in China and I was
before woke and all that I regret it I
could tell something was wrong I ordered
the bat and the guy said do you want
flies with that
I'm grossed out into applause I like
that it's a interesting switch on the
into applause thing but to know I'm not
worried about this they are close to a
cure and we're almost there they say the
last piece of the puzzle with the corona
virus is getting the lime into the IV we
don't want to make too much light there
are there are two cases in America they
are taking it seriously they are
examining people now who have traveled
internationally in who traveled
internationally in this time period just
got home President Trump they told them
for the next couple of weeks lie into
your elbow
now what else is in the news Oh Trump
yes the president United States is
getting impeached that's that happen
not a good thing and it's not gonna come
out right and of course this is the
Senate this is the Republicans turf it's
Mitch McConnell's rules but these rules
are strict no coffee you see that no
coffee no cell phones no talking and of
course no fax this Democrats tried to
have witnesses brought it no a trial
without witnesses I've if it seems it a
trial it it's like a Phish concert
without rolling papers I and I tell you
even without witnesses and they're
without the documents that they have to
it's still when you see the whole thing
laid out like this so indisputable Adam
Schiff I gotta say was magnificent did
you see this this is true even Lindsey
Graham as big a Trump lover as Lindsey
Graham went up to Adam Schiff and said
it was an honor just to ignore you
so that's where we are in America here
on January 24 2020 no matter what
President Trump does no matter how
heinous or obvious the crime he will get
a full and excited exoneration from the
Republicans in the Senate and therein
lies the difference between this
impeachment trial and the Clinton
impeachment trial the Clinton trial
began with the presidential [ __ ] this
one will end with luck
you